hi so i'll be talking about error
correcting codes for uncompressed
messages
which is a paper by opher grossman and
justin holmgren
so let's start by introducing the the
setting we talked about
and the setting is very similar to the
standard error our correcting code
setting so we have
two people alice and bob and alice wants
to send some message to bob
for example suppose she has some image
she wants to send to bob
and unfortunately their channel is not
perfectly secure
let's say that on this channel there
exists some adversary
and let's say he can corrupt up to three
percent of that
of the bits on this channel and there's
three percent of course we can change it
but
just to be concrete let's assume it's
three percent and let's assume the
adversary is
is worst case so in our setting we're
going to assume he's worst case
meaning he's computationally unbounded
and we'll assume alice and bob r
are bounded let's see their polynomial
time
and so what's the what's what can alice
and bob do in this setting so there's
there's kind of a classic solution
right so first what alice is going to do
is she's going to compress her message
as well she can
and then she's going to use an error
correcting code to send the compressed
message to bob
right so first of course she wants to to
compress right if she can compress
in a lossless way her message to
something half the size
then later when she uses the error
correcting code she's going to send half
as many bits to bob so she can
save on bits so the better her
compression is the fewer bits she's
going to have to send to bottom
and then the next thing is she's going
to want to use an error correcting code
right so an error correcting code is is
just something that allows
that even after a certain error certain
bits of the messenger flip bob can still
recover the original message
right cool
and so our work starts by looking kind
of
at this setting and something we we
notice is that
instead of viewing this compression
error correcting code as two
kind of individual separate steps we can
kind of think about them together
right so you could imagine that for
example doing the compression error
correcting codes together
allows you to do things faster or
achieve better rates right
it's worth noting that in the case that
alice and bob are unbounded
then shannon proved that first doing
compression and then error correcting
code is
in fact optimal but when alice and bob
are polynomial time machines
like they are here then it's different
for example you might have some sort of
some type of data for example in image
where you don't know how to compress
that well
but when you view compression and error
correcting codes together
you're able to get much better rates so
the idea is
instead of viewing compression as as a
problem and error correcting codes is a
problem
we view kind of for what types of data
can
can we do these both together and see
for
what types of data we can achieve
something better by doing them both
together instead of doing one and then
the other
so that's that's kind of a at the very
high level what the idea is
so let's be a little more concrete about
what we mean by an air correcting code
for an uncompressed message
so first first let's just write down the
definition for a normal error correcting
code
in the setting right so an error
correcting code is going to be a pair
of an encoding algorithm and a decoding
algorithm
so an encoding algorithm a decoding
algorithm
so that for every message
let's call it m
when i decode the encoding of the
message with some errors
i get the message again
we want to assume that there's at most
three percent errors
so that's what an air correcting code is
whenever i take a message from this
message space i encode and add errors
and decode it i get
my original message cool
and when we do deal with this something
we we often care about is the
relationship between
the size of e of m and the size of n
so between these k bits that it takes to
write down m and how big
the encoding is
and so with this in mind let's let's
write a slightly different definition
so a slightly different definition is an
error correcting code
for a set s
this is also going to be a pair of an
encoding and a decoding algorithm
so for all
messages in s when i decode
an encoding of m errors
i get that so let's compare this new
definition error correcting code for a
set s
versus the standard definition for
increment error correcting code
so the main difference is that over here
we wanted
every message in zero one to the k when
it's encoded
with errors and decoded to get the
original message over here we only want
for messages in s to be
to be properly decoded
so we can imagine s is some subset of 0
1 to the k
so we can think for example of s is the
set of all
for example valid images so suppose we
know alice wants to send bob an image
right maybe alice is texting bob an
image
so we know she's sending some image
so here that guarantees for any valid
image when i encode it add errors and
decode again
so maybe one way of thinking about is if
s is all the set of valid images
so anything that looks like a an image
is an s and everything that looks like
just random gray noise just like a
random array of
like random pixels is not an s
so in this new definition our guarantee
is whenever you send an actual image
right whenever you send
like for example a picture of something
that looks like a dog
then you encode it add errors and decode
and you get the original thing
but there's no guarantee over if you
send
like some random array of
great of like pixel there's no guarantee
and that makes a lot of sense because
alice doesn't actually care
how her error corrected code behaves on
random arrays of pixels
what she cares about is how the error
correcting code behaves on images
or you know similarly if she's sending
some audio
an audio file she doesn't care about how
the error correcting code behaves on
just like random white noise what she
cares about is
how it works on actual audio or if you
know she's sending
some english text she cares about what
it looks like when you send english text
and not want it what it looks like when
you keyboard match random characters
great so we can view this new definition
as
a relaxation of old definition where we
don't want a guarantee on all messages
we only want to guarantee
for messages inside the set of kind of
reasonable messages s
so this is like the set of reasonable
messages of
kind of of messages that it's plausible
that alice might
um send and we only want a guarantee
over those messages
cool great
so
with this new definition the the next
thing to do is to kind of ask
well what can we achieve what does this
definition
allow us to achieve so let's write down
a theorem statement
so
write it down and then we'll discuss it
okay so here's the theorem statement so
it's telling that us that for every
polynomial time recognizable set s
or s is small enough there's an error
correcting code
for up to three percent errors where the
size of the encoding is 1.74 k
and in a second we'll talk about the
exact rates
right so roughly the way i think about
it is whenever i have an s
that's polynomial time recognizable and
small enough i have an
error correcting code for s that's much
better than just encoding the whole
space 0 1 to the k
so kind of naively if you have some set
and
you know you don't know how to compress
it anymore you've tried compressing but
either you don't know or you don't have
the computational resources
to compress it but
the set s is still very small right so
information theoretically
i could have compressed it to size k
over two so information theoretically i
could have compressed it
but maybe due to computational
limitations or because i don't know the
right algorithms i'm unable to
so in that case as long as s is
polynomial time recognizable i can
encode it and get much better rates than
if i just
you know did the naive thing of encoding
all of 0 1 to the k
all right cool so let's look at this a
little more in detail for example let's
look at this polynomial time
recognizable thing
so polynomial time recognizable just
means that
given a string in 0 1 to the k you can
within polynomial time and k tell me if
you're an element of s or not
right so you can think um for example
let's think again if s is the set of
images so here we would require
that there's a polynomial time algorithm
for recognizing if something is an image
right so in practice like i i imagine
this doesn't exist but you can have you
can use like a heuristic algorithm for
checking if something is an image or not
and then set s to be the set of things
that pass this juristic algorithm
right and then furthermore we want s to
be small
and this makes sense because if you look
at the set of
all grids of pixels very few of them are
actually
valid images right so the set of valid
images is going to be very small
compared to the set of
all you know grids of pixels
or if you want to think about s is the
set of all valid english text so suppose
alice wants to send
english text right then 0 1 to the k
would represent all strings of a certain
size
and s will just be the strings that
actually make sense as english
that don't look like just keyboard
matching gibberish
so then s is going to be very very very
small right because if you just keyboard
match the probability that you'll get
an actual english something that makes
sense in english is going to be
extremely extremely small
and we assume there's a polynomial time
recognizable way of doing it
all right great so for these there will
exist an error correcting code
where the encoding of the message is of
size 1.74 k
and to compare it let's compare it to
what's what we could have done otherwise
so suppose we have
the set s we tried com compressing it
but
we're unable to maybe because we don't
have computational resources maybe
because we don't know the right
algorithm
um there's a bunch of reasons why we
might not be able to compress it
but just knowing it's it's size and
knowing that it's polynomial time
recognizable allows us to guess 1.74 k
if we didn't have this idea of creating
an error correcting code just for s
we would be stuck in in trying to
find the error current contain code for
all of zero one to the k right so the
naive thing to do
if you don't know about this idea for
finding an error correcting code just
for s
is to find an error correcting code for
the whole space zero one to the k
and if you find an error correcting code
for the whole space 0 1 to the k
the best you can do before work is 2.52
k
as the size of your encoded message or
2.27 k is the size of your encoded
message so
so 2.52 is the best known before our
work and our work actually
as kind of as a corollary of the stuff
creates better randomized
codes that are efficiently decodable and
encodable
so with randomized codes after our work
you can you can lower it down to 2.27
but either way it's it's higher than
this 1.74 of when you just look at s
so that's the idea and of course in our
in our paper it's not like specific to
three percent errors in this size but
there's
this whole trade-off between size and
and amount of errors and and all that
and it's kind of a mess to write down
what this exact
trade-off is and it depends on on prior
works because what we do is we build
upon
like previously constructed codes um
so if you want to know the exact details
and trade-offs you can look at the paper
but i think this this example of
parameters kind of
kind of highlights like highlights
what's
what's new and you can just imagine how
how things
how things change when you change the
errors when you change the side of that
the size of s and so on
cool and so let's let's just give a
quick
a quick idea of how how we construct
these things
so kind of a proof scratch
so proof sketch so the idea is to use
list decoding
okay so some of us might know what list
decoding is but let's let's give a
quick intro to list decoding anyway so
list decoding is similar to normal error
correcting codes where i take some
message
and i encode it and add errors
and then i decode it and then usually in
normal error correcting codes i would
just get my message on
but over here it's a little different
i'm going to get a list of messages
one m2 m3 up to polynomial size
um let's call it m s
cool so i get some list with the
guarantee that at least
one of these messages is m so
m is somewhere in the list so that's the
idea
and why do we like list decoding because
we get better rates
so if you want unique decoding you're
going to get worse rates than if you're
okay with list decoding
so if you're cool with having a
polynomial set list of options where
one of the one of the options is your is
your real message
then you can get better rates this is
this is our starting point and so here's
the idea suppose alice takes a message
and sends it over to bob and you know at
the end you get a list
kind of if she's lucky what's gonna
happen is
of course the message has to be there
and then there's going to be some other
strings
right
you could imagine this is the list so if
you get
you you got a message you decode it into
a list and you got this list
you can kind of be pretty confident that
these two
weren't what's meant and hello was the
message that was actually met
the the message that was actually sent
right you look at it you see two things
that are gibberish and one thing that
makes sense and so you know it's a thing
that makes sense
right or imagine you know you you get a
big list of images one of them is a
picture of a dog and then
there's 99 pictures that look like
random gray static noise
then you can be pretty sure that it's
the dog that was the picture that was
meant to
so that's the idea so the idea is if we
can augment list decodable codes to make
sure that they behave in this way then
that would be great
so of course the problem is right
something that would be bad if
in this list there was another
reasonable message right
another message in s that would be bad
right so so our work
can at the high level can kind of be
viewed as making sure
that with high probability we create
these list decodable codes so that with
high probability
there's in the list there's only going
to be one element in s
one element that looks reasonable
so formally we want one thing to be an s
and everything else to not be an s
cool so that's the idea
um and going a
step further the way we kind of do this
is we create a pairwise random
permutation we can permute the messages
and then encode them encode them using a
known list decodable code
and then you can you can check that if
this gnomeless decodable code
has certain good combinatorial
properties you can analyze it and show
that with high probability over the
choice of the
pairwise independent permutation um
everything works
and with high probability whenever you
encode something with s
your list will only contain
one element in s
so that's the idea
i think i think the main the main thing
i i find
interesting here is is kind of this idea
that
within error correcting codes you don't
have to think of your input space as
just 0 1 to the k or some alphabet to
the k
but in general you can think about
encoding sets in general
and it turns out
that you can get some some sort of
interesting and also pretty general
things about
s's for example if your s is small then
you automatically get much better
much better codes than encoding the
whole space they're in
and i imagine within error correctly
codes there's
there's probably more interesting to do
interesting things to do with this
it's also interesting that like like
using these techniques you can get
better
randomized efficiently decodable codes
than were known before
and yeah maybe also outside of error
correcting code this idea of
looking at your input not as from zero
one to the k but some
coming from some specific small set
within it
um could be interesting because in
practice a lot of our data isn't isn't
actually drawn from like zero one to the
k but it's drawn from a very small
subset of it
like if you're doing image analysis or
whatever i keep
using this this image example but a lot
of types of data are
actually they're they're not coming from
something that zero went
to the k but they're coming from
something much smaller
and maybe that can give speeds up speed
ups better rates
and who knows so yeah thank you